Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop today, we've got another fun project for you in the past
We've had several experiments where we made molds of organic things and then cast them in candy
We've got one more of those that we want to try today
I have here a cooked red lobster tail!
We're gonna see if we can melt down some swedish fish cast it in that mold and make a gummy red candy lobster tail
The first step is to build a box that we can pour our lobster tail mold in
There we go, we've got the walls of our box built from some Lego, but to make sure that they're completely
Watertight or silicone tight, let's just line the sides with tape a little bit
There we go that looks pretty good, I think
One more step before we start prepping our silicone
We've had a couple of problems in the past with some of the things we're trying to mold floating up
Inside the silicone, so let's make a couple of small holes in the base of our Lego plate
And then run some screws through the Lego plate into the lobster tail
Alright, I think that's done a pretty good job or lobster tail feels like it's fairly well in place now of course the screws sticking
Out the bottom have made it so it doesn't sit level so let's just add a couple of feet on the bottom
They won't fit into place on this plate, but let's use a few bricks and spread them out
And then we can set our mold on top of those bricks
There we go, that's sitting nice and level our
Next step is to mix up a good-sized batch of silicone that can completely cover this lobster tail
We've got some nice bright yellow catalysts here, and we need to mix it at a ten to one ratio
So if we have 20 ounces of our silicone then we need two ounces of our catalyst
There's two and let's just go a little bit more because we have a little over twenty ounces of our silicone
Looks kind of like a giant fried egg in there
now just get to stir all of our silicone and catalyst until it is nice and evenly mixed
and then we'll throw it in the vacuum chamber and pull out all the bubbles
All right, let's start pulling a vacuum
There it goes
Here we go
All right there we go, we've got our silicone poured it's mostly bubble free
now we just need to let our mold sit for a few hours until it's completely cured
All right our silicone mold has now had several hours to cure
And it is nice and rigid it started pushing the tape out on one side, but it didn't spill over anywhere
So I think we are good, and I think it's time to start pulling this mold apart, and see how it turned out
Well, that's a good texture
You can see the little
Bits and edges of the lobster where it was basically in contact with the plate
Yeah, see this is the annoying part is the bricks come apart from each other, but then they're stuck to the tape
on the side wall
There we go Lego brick walls are free
I'm off a little bit of extra spilled over silicone here and there
There we go we've got our block mold now when we just need to free the lobster tail from within
Now you can see the inside of some lobster tail in there
Cracking parts of the shell I have already accepted the fact that to get this out we're probably
Going to have to break the lobster tail into a lot of pieces. That's alright
We should still have our mold
That does not smell really great mm-hmm
Powerful fish smell
oh there we go all these little pieces that angle down like that those are really digging into the silicone
There we go, I think at this point
We've got most of the lobster tail out of the mold we had to cut parts of the mold open where there were long
Reaching bits of the tail, but I think we've gotten all of it out and at this point
We just need to wash it to try and get rid of some of that day-old lobster smell
It's really not a pleasant smell at this point let's try and see how well we can wash this
There we go, I think we've got our mold pretty well cleaned out at this point
It doesn't have much in the way of a pour spout
So let's cut a couple of holes into the bottom of our mold that will let us pour our liquid candy down inside
There we have it with our mold prepped
It's time to start melting down our swedish fish into a liquid that we can pour down into our mold
There we go we've got some swedish fish in a saucepan, let's add some heat and try and melt these things
Hmm
These don't really seem to be
liquefying
The way I was expecting them to
staying very stringy
Like there's no puddle forming on the bottom. It's just
Looking kind of like melting plastic
I'll let it go for a little longer and see what happens
Alright so
swedish fish
apparently don't liquefy when you heat them up they just turn into a
gross bubbly burning
gelatin
Mess. I don't think I'd be able to get this down inside the mold if I tried
So we're gonna have to move on to plan B
We have a jello candy recipe that we've used several times in the past
We're gonna try a slight variation on that I still want to get the red outside of our shell
But instead of just casting the whole thing in a red gummy
we're going to try using some red chocolate to make a nice thin coat on the outside of our shell and then we'll fill the
Rest of it with our gummy recipe we want it to be white so I found some clear gelatin and after
We've mixed it all up
I'll try adding a little bit of marshmallow cream to make it the opaque white color that we're going for first of course
Let's melt our chocolate
All right, we've got our chocolate. It's warm and melted in the bag. Let's try and squirts them down into our mold
hopefully we can get a nice even coating on the inside and then
pour out the extra if there is any
And make sure it gets all the way down into the little tail bits if there's any extra that wants to shake out
We go that looks like it's pretty well coated on the inside with our chocolate
But there's still plenty of Hollow in there for our gummy candy to finish it off there we go
We've got our chocolate coating the inside of our lobster tail mold now
Let's pop this into the freezer to cool down and solidify while we make our gummy recipe
Let's start with half of a cup of cold water and then add 1/4 cup of corn syrup now
Let's mix this until all of our corn syrup is nicely dissolved into the water
We'll know. It's ready when the mixture is completely clear and has no more cloudiness to it with our corn syrup dissolved now
Let's add two packets of gelatin powder into the water remember that at this stage. We haven't added any heat yet
This is still quite cold with our gelatin all mixed into our liquid
Let's add a little bit of heat and stir every minute or two to be sure everything stays evenly mixed there
We go I think our gelatinous mixture is all ready to go, so let's take it off the heat
And then add a little bit of our marshmallow cream
Now I've never done this before so I'm just kind of guessing on how much to add. Hopefully it melts in nicely
We definitely have a good opaque
Slightly off-white color. I'm thinking that actually looks pretty darn close to the color of the inside of the lobster
Let's try pouring this into our mold, and hopefully it won't completely melt the shell that we've already poured chocolate
Feels pretty nice and solid I think it's cooled off pretty well inside of the mold
Let's see if we can pour in this gelatin
All right, I think that's full
Now let's let that cool, and then we'll try and de molde this sucker there we go
We've let the candy cool down inside of our mold for several hours now
So it's time to see if we can pull this thing out in one piece
Almost seal itself back together. I've seen some good
results, but I think I'm also getting some cracking chocolate as long as it's held together in the long term like if
It's stuck to the candy well then I'm not too worried
This is all a bit of an experiment
Well, we've got some cracking and breaking there the chocolate may not have flowed very nicely into the very thin parts of this mold
We're D shelling or lobster tail
Chocolate seems to stick fairly well to the silicon more than I was hoping
Lobster puzzle here, I don't think I'm good enough at solving puzzles to fiddle these pieces back on
Feeling I know how this is gonna go, but let's see if we can get it out over the other side any better
Pretty good interior
Lobster
Unfortunately our shell
Does not like to participate?
at all
well the inside of our lobster tail is looking pretty great the
outside of our lobster tail
Really does not want to turn out very well
Sticking to the mold more than just about anything I've ever seen stick to the mold
Well making a red shell over our white inside didn't really work
the red shell wasn't strong enough to survive being d molded so I do want to try making a pure gummy lobster tail so let's
Mix up another batch of our gummy recipe pretty quick try pouring that in here and let's see what happens when that sets
Our mold is filled it has the two different layers with the red and the white gummy now
Hopefully when we let this cool down it will solidify into one beautiful lobster tail that has a red outside and a white inside
There we go what is hopefully our final gummy test has solidified
and now it's time to try and take it out and see if we managed to keep those layers of the top red and the
inner white
Good things
Uh-huh, yes
Ah
There we go a
lobster tail made of gummy candy
we don't have the
Perfect separation between the red layer and the white layer it looks like some of it managed to dissolve its way through in some spots
And of course there's a little bit of red that's bled onto the bottom, but for the most part
This is looking like a lobster tail we do have the red outside. We do have the white inside
That is what we want
Right now. I'm just cutting off the pour spouts because as I may have mentioned before real lobsters. Do not have pour spouts I
Don't want to set unrealistic expectations for all the other lobster out there
You're beautiful the way you are you don't need a pour spout
And just to try and match the look of the real lobster tail a little bit more
I'm taking a little bit of food coloring and a bamboo skewer and just painting on some details
At this point I would say there's only one step left to try and that is eating it all right, I think
You're supposed to split lobster using the knife to crack it Danny. I don't know
That's the official way right there
There's a cross-section some of the red definitely bled through all of the white we have almost a gradient
But you can see the different layer. This is our red layer
Separating just a little bit from our not so white layer
Now to eat our lobs. This is gonna turn my mouth so red because I've painted on it with food coloring
Alright, let's see how this goes
It's really
Really, sweet and a really weird texture. I think adding the marshmallow cream
Introduces a lot more air into this because usually with this gummy candy recipe
It's just kind of like a gummy candy. This is more like
Candy styrofoam
It's edible
But I wouldn't recommend it not my favorite candy. We've ever made, but one of my favorite looking candy things
We've ever made there you have it
Molding a lobster tail and casting it in gummy candy
We had a few hiccups along the way our
swedish fish did not work our
Chocolate with the gummy core didn't really work since our chocolate broke off and didn't stick to the gummy at all
But eventually we did get a read outside and a white inside all made of gummy candy, which looked really good
Especially after painting it with a little bit of food coloring
Thanks for joining us for this video today and remember to come grab your hats shirts another cool merchandise at the king of random calm
See you there
Mmm
Lobster not just for New England
Doesn't even make sense to eat lobster all over. Oh now a lobster tail is edible. Who'd have thought you couldn't eat them before oh
wait
you can't
Love your Channel TKOR!